clovis how's everybody doing don't have
an exciting day today we're going to
talk about doom and gloom that's why I'm
dressed appropriately for the occasion
anyways before I get into it I want to
cover some of the comments that were
made and that's regarding some of the
subjects we've been covering the last
couple weeks which is has to do with
what is an object what is time what is
motion okay especially those those three
and here's the first comment okay let's
get on with it that definition of time
needs sharpening up that's my definition
of time which is comparison of two
motions right not all the events in
physics involved motion oh you look up
the word you've and it says something
that happens
bla bla bla bla bla so yeah I guess
event means happens happens is a verb so
you have two or more locations per each
event okay and here you get a little
glimpse of that here let me put this up
here okay we discovered we cover that
the other day where we have this box at
different locations that's motion that's
an event there a little film strip you
need two frames but I put three just to
show that we have motion okay so yeah I
mean you know motion two or more
locations and that's what an event is
okay an object can remain in one
location and change state well I don't
know what state he's talking about maybe
California to New York I don't know what
it means change state a change the word
change is already motion okay let's keep
that in mind and so time is the
comparison of two motions or change of
state now no change of state and and
again he gives you a campo you'll see
why here he says for example in the
kitchen two eggs
could boil too hard one after the other
whilst eight-trey of water freezes we
have two things right eggs
tray of water right and so it is that
eggs boiled too hard at twice the rate
that water freezes so we're talking
about eggs versus water we're talking
about the motion happening to boiling
eggs and emotion happening to water so
we're comparing two motions anyways so I
don't think he made this case but maybe
you can try it better next time okay in
fact I think I covered that the other
day with good old Isaac Newton
supposedly he had three laws of motion
he never defined the word motion okay
I do not define time-space place and
motion because we all know what it means
right so I might take the trouble but
he's credited with the three laws of
motion the first and third really are
not his they belong to Rene Descartes
who came several years before he did and
the when I want to focus on is the law
the first law okay everybody continues
in its state of rest or of uniform
motion in a right line meaning straight
line right unless it is compelled to
change that state by forces impressed
upon it well dude had it wrong okay
Newton had no idea what he was talking
about because first of all there is no
such thing as rest not even God can rest
in this universe I'm gonna move God very
simple he could be as powerful as he
wants but here I moved my little index
finger and I'm moving God right now
because that atom there at the end of my
fingers changing his distance with
respect to God so not even God can stand
still in our universe okay and so I
don't know what he's talking about rest
and then the other one is uniform motion
in a straight line no such thing in the
universe you know right now we're
rolling around the Sun those who are not
flat or thirst okay we're rolling around
the Sun we're moving with respect to
Jupiter and we're moving with respect to
Alpha Centauri the three star system
closest to the earth and we're moving
with respect to the Andromeda galaxy the
center of the universe etc wherever
we're at so there is no such thing as
straight-line motion or rest and so I
don't know what Newton's talking about
but the Mathemagician do they you know
hammer a stake in the ground and they
use that as a corner right and they say
look we're going to use this as a frame
of reference and so they gauge all their
motion from that point and that's
cheating because there's no such thing
as a fixed point anywhere in the
universe now for mathematical purposes
they want to be able to control that and
say okay let's put that as point zero
that's the zero miles right there and
then from there we count motion and
whatever yeah they can do that that's
artificial but that doesn't that doesn't
affect the the fact that motion is is
universal and it's constant it's never
in a straight line okay you can do
whatever calculations you've done you
want and and put whatever scenarios you
want but that doesn't mean that motion
is in any wave fixed from a given point
we do that on earth to do our
calculations it's got nothing to do with
the real physics that Mother Nature runs
out there okay that's my point okay
let's get this one out of there another
comment here says the turn C discusses
meaning right may have already been
defined oh they have I couldn't find a
single definition bouquet and it would
be great if he stuck with those
definitions okay and he gave a series of
links there and I didn't copy the links
but those are the questions that were
addressed at each one of those links I
looked at a few of them too many really
for what they were worth but here it is
what is time and says curved time that's
what this guy talks about the link where
that was at curve time says time is
crude and yeah that's what general
relativity says I mean it's that's what
they say now whether
since that's a separate issue they say
curd time why because you got explain
why the earth doesn't run away from the
solar system okay and how did the
relativist do it well they say look
we're gonna warp space-time so they're
gonna use this depression in space-time
which means they're gonna warp
space-time they're gonna use it as a
wall and they're gonna say that you know
the earth goes around this wall that's
that's what the insane field equations
say earth rolls around this wall like a
little ball around the roulette okay
that's what their that's their mechanism
that's our physical interpretation of
their equations and that's why the earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system for
that they had to bend time and even this
guy admits you know it doesn't make any
sense but as he says you know
predictions match reality in other words
they say you know whatever the equations
say that's what we see out there
well no kiddin that's what the equations
say because the equations are tailored
to what we see out there it's a
description of something invisible which
in this case is space-time and so the
equations had better match what we have
out there because they're just
descriptions it's like saying you know a
chair has four legs and you say well is
that true well yeah I mean you know
here's the equation to equal four legs
you know and it's a fact by simply
because it's a fact but but you know
it's the question is what is the
mechanism for it for bending of time how
can you imagine such a monster and
that's where the problem comes in and
that's and this guy even says it in his
in his YouTube video ok then he talks
about forward in time what does that
mean what do you mean is time uh like a
box and you move forward through the box
through this container is that what time
is some kind of physical entity it talks
about how causality
you know that that's essentially the
definition of time now he has no
definition time nobody out there has one
that's why we had to define the word
time for the mathematicians we have no
you
for time in physics because time is only
a description in physics we explained
and science we explained so time has
nothing to do with either physics or
science okay what is an atom okay let's
see what he showed for an atom is
there's his famous atom and it's
anatomize seen before somewhere I don't
know and says the nucleus is made of
protons and neutrons and there's a cloud
of electrons surrounding it these are
his words okay and so he's only got to
answer one question and that's the only
question that Niels Bohr has to answer
and all these other fellows and that's
and the issue there is why do do those
electrons stay glued or faithful to the
nucleus why don't they just
spontaneously fly away what's keeping
every electron buzzing around like bees
around the hive you know this is what
you get answer yeah you got answer what
physical entity is in contact puts
contact or makes contact between the
electron and the nucleus that's what
they got answer okay and until we have
an answer to that you don't have an atom
because that's the only answer that
that's the only question you have to
answer okay energy what is energy well
he had a big hard time with that one and
here's his reply and this is the fellow
and he's great as a clown no doubt about
that you should be a stand-up comedian
but the science he delivers is man it's
way off the mark okay so I don't know
about him and he says energy isn't
something tangible no kidding energy is
a concept that better not be tangible I
can't touch love I can't touch
information and I can't touch energy or
mass or field energy is not a thing by
itself correct it's a property of things
correct
so what's what the heck is energy and
then he says energy is the amount of
stuff that could happen and so these are
the definitions he says this fellow says
our you know ground in stone and that I
should work with those definition
no way this is garbage this is nonsense
poppycock and then he goes with field
and what is a field well he says
assigning numbers to places okay so here
I've got a little uh little thing if I
find it here here is field of numbers
okay here's the field of numbers so this
is his oh sorry wrong one let me get
this one right there it is that's what I
wanted to say do er hominin okay so
that's what he says he says the
assigning numbers to places well there
you have a bunch of numbers to places
that's a field that's a vibrating field
does that make any sense is that is that
a physical entity just a bunch of
numbers that are vibrating her or
assigning numbers to places so no we
can't use any of the definitions this
guy is proposing okay this is the
problem and then he goes to what is mass
and what do you say ability to resist
changes in motion and he gives the
example of force equals mass times
acceleration he says when mass goes up
acceleration goes down because there's
more resistance what does that mean what
is that that's a concept and they're
using this mass concept to say that a
singularity which has infinite density
which has infinite mass and zero volume
right infinite density has an effect on
a star far away what I want to know is
what's what's the mechanism how does a
singularity physically affect a star far
away that's what we need to understand
and for that hopefully he doesn't put
spirits in between that space and
between the singularity at the star so
you know the black hole is nonsense
because they never defined the word mass
primarily because of that and then there
there was a final point this false
mention and that was gravity and so does
he say if I
gravity well he says he sends us to this
guy's site again this is what this
fellow says so so look at what he's
saying okay let it start again here give
me a second okay here it starts and he
says a falling person is being attracted
toward every particle in the earth when
you're outside the earth all those
particles are underneath them but once
they're inside some of those particles
are above them some of the earth is
pulling them upward which makes them
lighter okay that's why you move slower
into the earth if you were to make a
hole into the earth that's his
explanation but he's being attracted by
every particle on earth and the question
is how do those particles attract him I
mean are we gonna put angels there
spirits what are we gonna use how does a
particle attract you one and how does a
particle pull you from behind as he's
saying there okay because he says once
you enter the perimeter of the earth if
you go into that hole that you made into
the earth all the way to the center now
he's got particles pulling you from
behind you so how does a particle pull
on you that's the issue and that's the
something that quantum will never be
able to answer never will be able to
answer that question because you can't
pull with particles and that's what's
wrong with quantum and that's why it's
garbage total garbage total nonsense
you can't pull with discrete particles
you can't get a physical interpretation
for gravity using particles and just in
case we'll put a little L thority for
those people who like Authority and
proof and evidence and experiments okay
so here we have Authority okay and this
is Richard Muller from UC Berkeley and
he says so for example if you have the
earth there's the a big mass here and
you have you with your little mass here
and that's you there on top of the earth
the big mass that Big M that's the earth
and you're sitting on top of the earth
okay and what he says he says every atom
on earth is pulling
pulling on every atom of you you're also
pulling pulling on it the amazing thing
about gravity is that it goes right
through things so how do you pull with
particles how does an atom pull on you
and atom from the earth right and yeah
under the rope model is its kids play
it's a a child can understand it and
what's the difference okay well here we
have mathematical physics discrete
particles and the Rope hypothesis every
atom is interconnected in the universe
that's where the difference comes in
okay so so if you want to know the
difference there you have it the rope
hypothesis says all atoms are
interconnected and yeah now we can
explain gravity very easily because what
that's let's wait for it to start here
so now he says a falling person is being
attracted towards every particle in the
earth yeah because they're tied to it
and when they're outside the earth those
particles are beneath them but once it
ends they're inside some of those
particles are above them so now you see
them pulling from behind you that's why
because now you're dragging against
those particles that are tucked behind
you oh you can only explain gravity with
elongated objects our entities and the
way we do it is saying that all atoms
are interconnected physically
interconnected okay
and of course uh people say how do they
get tangled how come I can't see them
how can i how come I can't touch them
and I've covered that subject at nauseam
so I'm not gonna get into that but the
point is the only way you can show it is
action at a distance is that you don't
see the mediator and there's better be a
mediator otherwise you're feeling that
same space with spirits energy mass
field those are all spirits that
mathematical physics invented okay and
so why don't you fly off the earth very
simple because every atom in your body
is tied to every atom on earth why
doesn't the Chinese man on the other
side of the planet
fall off like the flat earthers say well
because every atom of his body is also
tied to every atom on earth and so he's
being pulled towards the center just
like you doesn't matter which way that
ball the the earth right is facing we're
all pointed towards the center of the
earth why because we're all physically
tied to the center of the earth okay
okay but what got me rolling let's let's
begin our extinction theory today let's
find out what's going on starts with
this comment that someone made and this
person says the inability to grow store
grains at scale those are guide
Macpherson's worse describing how
extinction would likely take place not
sure how this message is different than
mr. Gailey guy has been saying this for
decades whoa why do folks diss the
original messenger jealousy a bris it's
sad well what is sad is that this person
didn't take the trouble to figure out
what this site is about first of all and
what I've said because I've written it
in my book and it differs completely
from from what guy McPherson said and
he's not fearsome he's just McPherson
okay and this is a discussion I had with
McPherson and a person who represented
him okay some time ago and this is what
he what I told him I said guy McPherson
is an idiot he is an idiot because he is
an environmentalist an environmentalist
is an idiot because he believes that
humans are in danger of going extinct
because of climate change or because we
are too many and our ruining our
environment please do not confuse me
with guy McPherson
he is a conservationist a climate change
er an individual who has no clue
whatsoever about extinction
it is idiots who believe that humans
will go extinct because of the
environment or pollution or because we
are too many the guy knows didn't
disappear because the climate change or
because an asteroid struck the earth or
because of pollution
they went extinct like humans will go
extinct starvation it is when we when
food runs out that mass extinctions
occur so what is the issue the issue is
that God McPherson is a climate change
er he has no clue about extinction he's
never done extinction in his life no
environmentalist has ever done
extinction just like no economist has
ever done extinction and and that's
really done up their alley it should
have been the economist who should have
figured out extinction of the human race
they never did because they're all so
busy with the stock market and interest
rates and other nonsense and so they
never figured out what causes the what
will cause the extinction of man and
what caused the extinction of past
species okay so let's get first some
statements because you know guy
McPherson does say that it's food that's
gonna kill humans and so this person
here says oh he said it already before
you did I don't know about that but
let's concede so he said starvation well
he's not the first one he that we've
been saying starvation for a long time
here are the some of the comments made
in different sources and you have for
the Ordovician period the entire base of
the food chain is wiped out okay so
we're talking about food right permian
with vegetation the foundation of the
food chain starvation now runs rampant
okay so we got that cretaceous
photosynthesizing organisms including
photo plant phytoplankton and land
plants formed the foundation the food
chain in the late cretaceous as they do
today evidence suggests that herbivorous
animals died out when the plants they
depended on for food became scarce
consequently top predators such as
Tyrannosaurus Rex also perished Holocene
major destruction of the vegetation -
burning over broad areas of the
continent would have destroyed the food
sources for many of these animals and we
suggest that is why the larger animals
preferentially became extinct so if
you're going to talk about food
you know or starvation that's been
mentioned for a long time I didn't
invent starvation neither did Macpherson
we didn't invent the start with the
starvation scenario I think I think
that's been there for a long time what's
the difference the difference is the
trigger we need to figure out what
triggers starvation what's triggers the
mechanism that ends up depriving animals
of food including us what's going to
deprive us of food that's where we have
the difference McPherson says it's
climate and I think that's totally
[ __ ] it's demented you know I mean I
have no respect for that at all
anyone who mentions climate change
should be executed kicked out of science
there's they're serious garbage
climate change never never in the
history of life on earth wiped out a
single species climate has nothing to do
with anything okay in fact the way I put
it in my book why God doesn't exist
that's the name of my book the way I put
it is that climate only favours the next
generation after the big guys are out
after the mass extinction occurs what
ever survives which is another food
chain parallel food chain those are the
ones which are favored or unfavored by
the climate because some animals will at
that better and no you know right for
the new niches because there's new food
on the ground and that's what they're
gonna that's when climate change if
anything has an effect but never for not
for the end of a a period in which ends
in mass extinction mass extinction is
not caused by climate change and as all
these people who study you know the
oxygen level the carbon level they're
[ __ ] individuals all they want is
funds from for their projects and then
they come out and they prove what they
set out to probe miraculously you know
you have all these people studying
climbing and say oh it's the carbon
cycle this guy studies the carbon cycle
comes back says
I've got a theory it's the carbon cycle
the other guy says it's the oxygen cycle
or the hydrogen cycle or whatever in
nitrogen or whatever in comes back and
says oh it's the nitrogen cycle because
that's what they receive the funds for
and that's they end up proving their
foregone conclusions so that's the way
it works in the real in the world of
science in the world of scientific
literature as they call it okay okay so
do they mention starvation at all I mean
they you heard some statements right now
about starvation is there a theory of
starvation anywhere on planet Earth
has there been one in the last 200 years
the answer is no here's here's the
breakdown okay two sources one is from
how stuff works the other ones for
Berkeley University there are two groups
of extinction theories listen carefully
okay
catastrophic extinction and gradual
extinction that's it
catastrophic extinction would have been
caused by a sudden external events such
as collision of the earth with an
asteroid or eruption of a series of a
gigantic volcano okay gradual extinction
would have been a result of changes in
the Earth's landmass and climate shifts
okay it would also have been because new
and better animals won in the struggle
for existence competition they always
bring that stuff in we competed against
the Neanderthals and so on okay the
other one Berkeley two main camps exist
in paleontology today the intrinsic
gradualists and the extrinsic extrinsic
catastrophists the intrinsic gradualist
volcanism and plate tectonics the
entrance extrinsic catastrophes a large
extraterrestrial object collided with
the earth astronomical stuff you know
something which NASA likes a lot because
they fund these projects they say hey go
study see if I'm supernova killed the
Ordovician animals or go study you see
if you know an asteroid hit the earth
during the Cretaceous and so it's self
interest because they need for people to
think that it came from came from out of
space it came
out of the sky as Creedence would say
okay that's that's that's all
self-interest it's got nothing to do
with science
none of that yeah okay so so here's a
just to make sure I cover guy McPherson
to make sure that that's what he said
I'm not gonna put words in this mouth
I'm gonna use their words put it here
here's a foe who representing him named
Davis most of his research referring to
guy McPherson had to do with range
science that is under what conditions
will the crops that humans and other
hands be able to survive it was while
editing a book in 2002 unchanged
changing precipitation regimes and
terrestrial ecosystems that he realized
that as the climate became hotter those
crops would not be able to survive and
mass starvation would be the result well
I like the fact that they said 2002 you
know I wrote my book in 1998 so maybe
even before a guy was born you know for
all I know but by 2007 he thought that
global warming could be stopped if there
was a collapse of industrial
civilization however in 2010 he read a
paper on global dimming and realized
that if industrial civilization would
collapse the warming would occur even
faster what is guy talking about he's
talking about climate change warming of
the clothes of the earth he says those
are going to destroy crops and that's
why we're gonna starve okay so the
trigger in in Macpherson's theory is
climate let's let's make sure that you
understand that okay that's not the
trigger in my theory at all theory here
is economics money money will disappear
money will be no more trade will be no
more we're gonna stop trading because
there will be nothing to trade hunter
gatherer who has food he doesn't trade
food with the other guy for food no way
and that's what people today don't
understand hunter-gather special ebay so
hunter-gatherers like nano felt they
never did
except to some [ __ ] into
paleontologists such as John Hawkes who
thinks that they traded seashells I
don't know for pop prostitution I don't
know what he's got going through this
brain this guy doesn't know the first
thing about anthropology and and he
supposedly uh got a PhD or who knows
where he got it some some church okay so
here here's the step by step so I want
to make sure you understand and guy
McPherson is talking about climate he's
not talking about the cannot the economy
okay so here he goes he says these are
the steps okay he goes through whether
you believe it or not this is what he
says The effect of this temperature
increase is that these plants will die
and mass starvation will be the result
climate yeah mass starvation in turn
will mean a collapse of industrial
civilization and a steep reduction in
the burning of fossil fuels okay this
might seem beneficial at first since
there would be a reduction in the
emissions of co2 and other so-called
greenhouse gases but the global average
temperature will continue to rise due to
the emission generated over the last 10
20 years see if you have all these
fluorides that we sent out into space
allegedly those eat up a lot of the
ozone layer leave holes or thinner
layers of ozone and the Sun can get
through there and kill the plants or
warm the climate to the temperature of
the earth to a higher degree that's
that's essentially the theory okay so
it's got to do with that and so here's
the other part of that hope I put it in
the right place put it on the right here
so you can see it side by side quits and
I said no but in here okay and here it
is he continued says however the
reduction in the burning of fossil fuels
will also result in the reduction of the
emissions of aerosol particulates such
as so3 predicting from dirty coal which
reflects solar energy back into space
before it reaches the earth the so
called global dimming effect great these
aerosol particulates fall out of the
atmosphere in oh man
weeks or months and the global average
temperature will rise another three
degrees causing the extinction of
virtually all living beings on earth
this could happen by next spring or the
spring of the following year so be
prepared now he said this like two years
ago but you know it's not that I'm gonna
make fun of him because of the timing
the timing is not important he screwed
up on the timing that's like me I
screwed up on the tiny as well you know
our crystal balls are a little dim okay
that's not the point the point is the
mechanism and the mechanism that
McPherson proposes is climate change he
says something happens to the atmosphere
because we're polluting it and that's
gonna affect the climate inside the
earth and it's gonna rise to a higher
degree in one of the two it kills us
directly or it burns all our crops and
where crops don't grow and so we all
starve to death that's his theory in one
way or another
that's not my theory whatsoever that's
not the trigger in my theory for that
matter you you know you've got people in
the Cretaceous the Alvarez theory of the
asteroid theory which is a ridiculous
theory says that an asteroid hit the
earth and that asteroid triggered a
whole bunch of phenomena then ended up
killing all the dinosaurs otherwise they
would still be in New York City okay
that's what these guys are saying and
you know what can I say it's it's
absolute nonsense so what is the theory
okay let's go with the theory let's go
with my theory to compare against guys
okay and here it is in a nutshell
okay the history of life on Earth what
do you see there I'm not gonna talk
about the nonvascular is what came
before say the Carboniferous and so on
because it's I'm not gonna go into any
details I just want you to focus on the
three major area
eras the H affirms the age of conifers
and the age of flowering plants okay so
what is the age of ferns the age of
ferns means that during off in like a
hundred million years we had primarily
firms dominate the landscape
that's what it was and there were a
certain animal especially the synapses
that grew in conjunction with those
plants that's what they ate because
there was nothing else around or that
was what mostly covered the vegetation
on earth then you know when that cycle
ended what started was the age of
conifers specially cycads and cycads
cycad light Williams so nians and so on
and this is the age of conifers and this
is the age of dinosaurs essentially it
involves the Jurassic and the Cretaceous
Jurassic you had the long neck's those
are the most prominent animals the
Cretaceous we have typically the t-rex
there and then we went that died 65
million years ago and what continued was
the age of flowering plants ok so this
is the history of life on Earth of
plants when the plants died the animals
that forged a relationship a long-term
relationship a hundred million year
relationship with those plants when the
plants go those animals go because they
can't switch their diet at the last
moment and start eating weeds you know
as far as the synapses and the
mammal-like reptiles that as they're
known in the in the Permian as far as
those animals were concerned the
conifers that were starting up the site
cats I can use which were tiny tiny
plants at the time they had these big
forests of ferns and that's what they
ate and all this other stuff
they were weeds they didn't eat that
stuff and who grew with those well the
little tiny animals are gonna become
first your co-stars that's in the
Triassic but then later on the dinosaurs
and so this group went down the other
the other food chain continue rolling
because it didn't affect them at all
what was happening to the synapses and
the mammal-like reptiles when those
animals collapsed
they collapse because the food chain
collapsed and those animals that did not
belong to that food chain continued
roaming no problem at all same thing
happened at the end of the Cretaceous
when the conifers went down became
extinct or not became extinct did he
become completely extinct but the forest
shrunk
the land was eaten up by the by the
angiosperms as the angiosperms took more
and more land the dinosaurs were left in
smaller and smaller islands forests
jungles there the world was collapsing
and so not only did they lose species
number of species over time because
there were not enough niches to occupy
but but they were fewer fewer animals
eventually until they finally became
extinct because you know you need food
to feed these animals and they they
forge a relationship of hundreds of
millions of being a hundred million
years at least where these plants
they're not gonna change their diet at
the last moment say now I'm gonna eat
angiosperms I'm going to eat the
flowering plants I'm gonna make no
year's in roses no way they as far as
they were concerned those were weeds
okay and and yeah that's when they were
replaced by the mammals so this is
predictable that one when not if but
when because this is the history of life
on Earth when a certain type of plants
very general family of plants right goes
extinct the animals that forge a
relationship with them will go also will
also go extinct what does that mean a
mass extinction can be predicted if you
stood at the Cambrian line and you know
542 million years ago if you stood there
and look forward you can predict that is
when this plant disappears all the
animals that depended on these types of
plants they will disappear as well and
there is no theory among palaeontologist
that says that it's a predictable theory
you should be able to put your finger in
and say look when the plant disappears
the animals will disappear and what are
these people thinking of I'll go switch
their diet now they're will they'll be
eating
weeds instead of you know what they ate
so if they were aiding eating conifers
like you know the cones of cycads
maybe that's what they were eating oh no
there's no more cones no problem we'll
just eat peaches how's that or lettuce
you think that's possible does a rabbit
switch to pine trees or pine leaves when
he doesn't have any carrots or or
lettuce do you think a rabbit would eat
that just because a plant is a plant as
a plant so any plant will do now of
course not rabbit is is tied to led us
to grass to stuff that he eats he he's
tied to the grasses essentially those
are called grasses you know the corn and
weed and all that so whatever they eat
it's it's grasses and they don't switch
over to firms
no no mammal eats ferns and no mammal
eats conifers you know so this is what
you got to keep in mind you're not gonna
switch at the last moment to another
type of food and until you understand
this you don't understand extinction and
if you don't understand extinction which
is extinction 101 you can't move on to
extinction 102 which is the human
extinction everybody is an expert in
human extinction and why humans are not
going to disappear oh they're expert
everybody's an expert on that they can
talk hours on why man is not going to
disappear because you know all they talk
about is politics and how they can
handle the economy and blah blah blah
not one of those persons is an expert on
extinction see first you got to tell me
how the animals in the past died okay
you got to tell me how the Triceratops
died you have to tell me how the arcus
arse died you have to tell me how the
synapses died when you're an expert
there then you can take you know
extinction 102 which is human extinction
and so if all mass extinctions all mass
extinctions were due to starvation
because the food disappeared the the
primary production disappeared from
under the feet of the animals these wild
animals and that's when they died when
they couldn't find anymore
or it was harder and harder to find food
as as their their sources dried out well
then the herbivores first died and what
followed were the carnivores so now you
can understand that you can understand
extinction and if that's how they all
these mass extinctions occurred what's
gonna change with humans can we avoid
extinction somehow and the answer is no
the answer is no because we produce our
own food and we only do it for money so
we don't have to look at climate change
we got to look at money we got to look
at what produces food what produces food
is money that's what produces food okay
without money there's no production of
food today we have all these big
corporations agricultural corporations
what they do they produce the food and
distribute it to the cities and all you
got to do is have some money and that's
created by the service economy a fake
economy where like I said the other day
it's a an unemployment economy anyone
working in services is unemployed and
you say bill you're crazy well let me
let me enlighten you the other day the
United States lost 30 million workers 30
million people went to the unemployment
line and I guess 90% of them were hotel
restaurants airline you know tourism did
we suffer at all not at all because we
don't need those jobs now not for I mean
we need those jobs to make a buck yeah
but we don't need those jobs to survive
on earth because all those people were
unemployed to begin with there were not
real jobs a restaurant and hotel yeah we
don't need those you can stay at home
you don't have to go on vacation you can
eat at home ok why don't we go to the
hotels to sleep and why do we go to
restaurants to eat well because it's a
luxury we go on vacation maybe or maybe
we have to go to another sea for work or
whatever so we go to a hotel and then we
go to a restaurant or you might take the
old lady you know I'm once they say hey
you know stop cooking tonight we're
gonna go to a restaurant and eat over
there
it's a luxury because what you have this
waiter he comes over and he says yes sir
what would you like and and you say well
I like a good beefsteak and good bottle
of wine so the guy goes out he does all
this work cook over there as well and
they bring it to you and they serve you
so it's a luxury economy you know all
that stuff is not needed and we showed
that you don't need it because you know
30 million workers went out of work and
no one felt the pinch of that in other
words no one died of starvation because
of that okay we didn't need those jobs
and that shows that that was
unemployment masked unemployment and
then you have the situation where you
know you you've got all these other jobs
that are dependent on that what do we do
what we earn a salary wages or whatever
so that we can exchange it essentially
for food we all work for food even Bill
Gates works for food and he's got
billions and he could by billions of
food but he doesn't eat billions of food
he doesn't eat billions of pounds or
kilograms of food he just as much as you
do and that's all you need to live one
more day because if Bill Gates doesn't
eat for 5 days or 10 days or a couple
weeks or a year I'm sure he's gonna die
ok so that's all he needs every penny we
produce in the service economy has just
read into the economy by buying food
that's what it is and yeah now we have
all this food that suddenly disappeared
from the cells mushy toilet paper why
you would say why would fool disappear
why didn't people just continue buying
normally what has food suddenly become a
problem you would think that ok so we
kicked a lot of workers out of their
jobs ok so we keep buying food normally
and we have the regular flow of food
into the supermarkets why is there
suddenly a big problem with food where
where food is scarce where here in
Germany where I'm at
food is limited to two packages per
person in other words if you buy flour
if you buy rice if you buy I don't know
spaghetti
well you're limited to two packages they
won't let you take more than two in most
stores at least and so the question is
why why Rajini I mean you would think
this is a bonanza for the big
corporations and they would start saying
hey you know this let's put more food
out because people are buying less this
is a chance to make a killing that's not
what happening it's not capitalism with
what was implemented with communism
rationing and so get ready for some big
problems because all these countries
advanced nations they're gonna be
rationing everything my nieces my
nephews who live in Japan they have the
same situation over there they say the
food is being rationed especially in
Japan which imports probably most of its
food so yeah food is the first thing you
got to think about and it's got nothing
to do with climate change it's got to do
with the economy as you can see okay so
let's see here's the another version of
the history of plants okay so that you
can get a snapshot and again you can see
that certain plants dominated during
certain periods of human history of the
history of life on Earth and those
plants are no longer dominant in fact a
lot of them went extinct altogether the
cycads the cycad likes yeah they're gone
the you know we only see them in the
rock these days and figure out you know
how this plant could have been okay and
yeah so you can see the trend there
those plants disappear whatever animal
carved a niche in those plants they're
gone okay and that's what a mass
extinctions is all about here's a here's
another version the chronological this
is specifically for the Cretaceous but
it applies to any period and that's what
occurs in a mass extinction is a chrono
logical selectivity it's a chronological
extinction what dies are the old species
the ones that relied on old sources of
food and there's new sources of food
that are coming up which they don't eat
and those only favor the parallel food
chain so what died were ammonites
dinosaurs on land you had a lot of
foraminifera
die in the oceans die atoms and you owe
all sorts of animals that died in the
sea and on land Peschel ii the in the
sea you had the Moses ours the what is
it the big reptiles that dominated the
Seas well all those animals why because
they were old they they were part of the
food chain of animals that have been
around for 100 million years that's why
they died because it's the old that died
and the young that radiate once the big
guys are out of the way and those new
guys those young that that new
generation of animals those are the ones
that radiate become bigger and you know
take over certain niches they occupy
niches in the vegetation and so so
that's the story of life on Earth and
that's the story of a mass extinction
yeah it's got to do with an economic
collapse
it's the ecological pyramid that dies
and so let's talk about that here a
second if I can get it in here ok this
is a healthy pyramid that's what a
healthy ecological pyramid is you have a
ten to one ratio more or less between
trophic levels primary production is
about 10 to 1 to herbivores and
herbivores are approximately 10 to 1 to
predators that's a healthy pyramid ok
what is it man unhealthy pyramid well an
unhealthy period in MIT is what humans
have and here's the unhealthy pyramid
side-by-side Oh getting it up here ok
and you can see it doesn't look very
pyramidal it looks kind of wishy-washy
you have too many predators at the top
if it's the US right and you have all
these animals that we raised for meat
and then when the rest of our diet
depends on cereals primarily you know
all the cereals are grasses and so there
you have a snapshot of what's happening
now this I took this a few years back so
the numbers are higher now
but the pyramid is structure is the same
essentially what you have is many humans
close to 8 billion humans relying on
maybe I don't know today maybe it's five
point five billion livestock large
animals and then that does not include
chickens and fish but you got again 18
billion of those so you get a fair
amount of meat okay and the rest comes
from cereals and that come and that
accounts for 87% of our primary
production does that grow into wild
absolutely not all that stuff grows
where it grows in farms we farm we have
remember we have domesticated both
animals and plants at least since the
Neolithic so that's that's how we live
today but why do we produce this we
produce it for money right now you've
got farmers in in the United States
killing animals because they can't get
up the market I really don't know what
the problem is but apparently someone's
not buying those animals partly because
of this virus and so some of the plants
are being closed the the slaughterhouses
and that food is being destroyed and
it's all an economic issue you know
people are buying rice and whatever
maybe and toilet paper and they're not
buying you know meat and so I'm not sure
exactly what the problem is but it just
gives you an idea that this is an
economic problem exclusively this has
nothing to do with climate change okay
so let's get that straight the trigger
is what's different between some of
these people what I proposed okay and
let's see I got a couple more here so so
here's the summary guy what happens in a
mass extinction which is going to happen
to man is that we have the overturning
of the ecological pyramid essentially
and here's a diagram of that a little
picture we have a healthy one on the
Left which is ten to one ratio between
these three trophic levels and that
overturns essentially we have little
primary production some herbivores
eating on that and predators a bunch and
we're the Predators we're at the top
predator of the planet so we're the guys
who are in that pink spot on the top and
what's gonna happen is the phone chain
beneath us is gonna disappear why does
it disappear is it some kind of climatic
change we're gonna have climate change
is that what it is the heat to the cold
whatever is gonna affect our food chain
absolutely not
it's going to be the money what's gonna
happens our global economy is gonna
collapse and I've been saying that for
20 years now the virus only made it
apparent to many people okay and I'm not
saying it's gonna happen in the next few
days there's probably gonna be a
recovery to some degree but what are we
having we're having we're gonna have
eventually more and more unemployed
which includes all the service people in
the United States that's 80 percent of
the workers all those people as far as
I'm concerned or most of them are we're
gonna have some unemployment meaning
that inside they're now gonna be paid by
companies by private corporations
they're gonna be paid by government
through welfare or unemployment or
whatever and so we're gonna have all
this mass of unemployed people okay and
that number is gonna increase that's
what I'm predicting that's what I'm
saying that should happen and the
workers the people who actually have a
job they're going to be fewer and fewer
and so the real wages are gonna go down
why because the government has to print
money in order to pay those people who
don't work right now they gave about 2.2
trillion dollars to everybody you know
and that's probably the first
installment maybe there's another one
what does that mean you're evaluating
the real wages of those who work and at
some point at some point there's going
to be a special ratio where those people
who work cannot make it to the end of
the month a lot of them won't be able to
make it to the end of the month and it's
not going to pay for them to work they
might as well go on the unemployment
line or on the welfare line because
what's the point of working if you're
only going to get 95 percent of the
salary that you need to make it to the
end of the month that's the issue and so
I think that ratio is going to come
around the more money that is being
printed okay that's that's the theory
okay okay so one there was a comment
along those lines I want to address that
comment and this person has some correct
details with an incorrect conclusion
uh-huh okay the lack of money will not
make food disappear okay this theory is
based on the assumption that people do
things only for money which is simply
not the case
whoa people do things for other and
money I don't know I should ask the
prostitute down the corner see if she
does anything for other than money you
know we'll find out I'll ask her I'll
run I'll run a a poll among prostitutes
see if they do anything for anything
other than money also money will not
disappear there are a bunch of things
that can do that can and do substituted
temporarily and permanently as well
furthermore you forgot to give
definition of critical components in
your theory most of all money itself
what you do so probably in your physical
theory very correctly this theory is
extremely unimaginative to say the least
okay that's his criticism and so here
let me show you a little graph okay that
I had in one of my papers okay and this
is money through the ages essentially it
gets a snapshot and at some point you
know food was money if you go to the
Book of Ruth in in the Bible she was
paid with Bharti and she needed for her
mother-in-law as well so she worked hard
to get to rashes one for her mother one
for her
she was paid with food and and if you
look at the what is it the some of the
old codes like the Babylonian code or
the hittite codes again a lot of that
was paid with food they were in that
transition where they were receiving
coins but also when they were they were
doing things for food and then at some
point we went into gold and silver then
we went into paper money and today we
even got rid of all that and we have
electronic money okay in different ways
and so so we've had different kinds of
money and so this person's asks for
money what is the definition of money
okay see if I can find myself here so I
can put myself back in here so what is
the definition of money well we don't
need a definition for money and let me
tell you why because money is anything
that you trade the issue is trade not
money money is trade and trade is money
and the prostitute also she trades
something for money and what she's
trading is known as money she gives a
service and that that is money that's
cash taking she can take it to the bank
why because she receives money exchanged
for that so money is anything that you
trade if the other guy accepts it that's
money so if you trade a buffalo for I
don't know for a gun like the Indians
used to do you know ok that's money on
both sides so we don't need what I'm
saying is trade will be no more and so
it doesn't matter if the United States
takes the greenback and turns it into a
Brownback now and says well from now
we're gonna have brown bags no more
green bags okay it doesn't matter the
government still has debt up to its you
know head and it's got to pay the people
so that people don't starve and don't go
out stealing and robbing killing and so
to keep the peace they have to give them
money and they're gonna produce that
money out of the little machine you know
fact they don't even need the Machine
anymore just put another couple zeroes
in the global economy they just throw
them in there you know they just create
money from heaven and what that does is
devalue the the value the real value
wages of those who were
and so that's what's gonna happen from
now on it's just gonna be a D value a
constant devaluation of money how long
that's gonna last how long that process
gonna last well only God knows
up there right so that's that's what I'm
saying is gonna happen and so the other
thing I wanted to say before I leave is
this and it's got to do with a comment
made by guy McPherson and he said that
he this was the fellow who talked for
guy McPherson first and he said Davis
has relied on Arctic scientists to
establish the danger posed by the
warming of sea beds in the shallow
Arctic seas in terms of the release of
gigatons of methane and there's a lot of
theories on methane for the Permian
apatheia loonie called Paul Wignall he
talks about methane coming out of the
sea beds a bunch of nonsense they pay
him a trip to go to Greenland and I
think Iceland and just to study the
methane that comes out and wouldn't you
know it he proved that it is methane
that killed the Permian synapsis great
but the point I want to say is he's
claimed his claims are all based on peer
reviewed science peer review oh it's
peer reviewed okay and so the questions
who are the peer reviewers well it's the
guy who is sucked up because otherwise
he wouldn't get a job if he didn't or
wouldn't even get a degree if you didn't
suck up and those are the people who
perpetuate the previous theories that's
why you're not gonna get any theory from
any of these guys from the universities
because all they do is suck up they have
to suck up in order to pass the test to
get their degree and to get a job to get
a career so they're not thinkers you
you're probably gonna get a better
result from independent thinkers who try
to reason it out and not from these guys
who get a degree simply because they
mark the letter D on the test and that
was a correct answer because they just
memorized so so I don't give a damn
about peer reviewers I have lolene for
peer reviewers they they you know
not even worth talking about them anyway
these guys McPherson entered the discuss
he said Bill Gates doesn't use evidence
and he's not he's not read the abundant
evidence I've come compiled the color me
shocked yeah McPherson should take an
indoor introductory course in science
because he's he's still operating with
the old notion from the seventeenth
century art I arcade science and we
caught the silent not the scientific
method we caught the religious method
what he's doing his religion anyone
presenting evidence anyone who wants to
demonstrate anyone who wants to prove
he's doing religion we don't provide
evidence in science what we do in
science we explain a mechanism so that
you understand it now said not so that
you believe it whether you believe it or
not that your personal opinion doesn't
concern science at all so we do not
present evidence any person presents
evidence we call man idiot okay and he's
doing religion he's not doing science so
here here's the rational scientific
method so that people are come up to
speed there's been a change in the
paradigm there's been a paradigm shift
starting at the beginning of this
century 21st century and all those who
want to do science had better come up to
speed here it is okay and so what is
science science is rational explanations
and we do have a definition for both
rational and for the word explanation
I'm not gonna cover that today cover
that in the past physics what is a deal
rational explanations of phenomena okay
and we want explain causes and
mechanisms and the what is it the bottom
line for physics the is art the objects
you can't do physics without an object
to pay and in the case of philosophy we
have explain shion's four behaviors and
we try to explain reasons and purpose
okay
and the bread and butter of philosophy
is the concept where do we put
experiments well over there in religion
anyone presenting experiment we don't
do experiments at a conference what we
do at a conference is we explain
something so that people understand the
objective phenomenon that we're trying
to explain and in this case we don't
have no use for experiments because
experiment only has to do with evidence
and evidence has to do with persuading
and convincing the jury that's what
experiment and evidence have to do with
so we do not present evidence because
the prosecutor presents evidence only
when he tries to sway the jury to his
side of the case and yeah you have all
your supernatural theories which above
generally all the traditional religions
and then we have the irrational theories
which are the modern theories and there
you have all the mathematical physics in
its entirety theism atheism agnosticism
all those are irrational theories okay
and I've covered that in the past as
well so no need to re to rehash those at
least for those people who've been
following this channel so yeah in in
science we do not present evidence what
we do is explain a mechanism so the
person understands it and that's where
science ends what continues thereafter
is religion belief opinion whether you
believe the theory whether you believe
that's the mechanism mother nature uses
to do some of her dirty work or clean
work in fact right invisible work her
invisible agents like gravity right
that's your personal opinion we don't
care we just explained the mechanism so
that you understand it and with that
I'll see you what is it on Wednesday and
I hope you have a great week and I hope
the virus doesn't get you and at the end
or the world takes a little time and
time we'll see you there
bye bye